each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we're very glad to have crystals for
here to give a talk on quantum computing
she expects her PhD in computer science
from Columbia University in spring 2006
her research has concentrated on quantum
compilers content for torrents and
quantum error correction but the
technical interesting crew the broader
fears of data mining intrusion detection
and classical photons so in her research
she has developed the first layer the
software architecture for Conan
computers that maps a high level program
into for talent machine level
instructions she has also developed
method to analyze and simulate the
reliability of quantum circuits
including error correction circuit using
a one class support vector machines to
detect anomalies she has also developed
a new host-based intrusion detection
system for Windows registry anomaly
detection Krista thank you so hello um
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for having me here today to speak
about my research today I want to try to
answer the question is scalable reliable
quam computation possible so I first got
into quantum computing several years ago
when i was at princeton and i was taking
a course from andrew wiles and it was a
cryptography seminar and we had been
discussing RSA the RSA cryptosystem and
how is based on the inability to factor
the product of two large primes quickly
and this is why it was secure and then
one day during discussion someone
brought up the fact that there was this
algorithm out there that was fairly
recent at the time a few years old and
that was developed by peter shor that
actually was able to perform
factorization in polynomial time and
this astonished everyone in the course
and we all said oh we want to learn more
what is quantum computing what is the
device and why does it have so much
power so I began to look at quantum
computing and have focused on quantum
computation for my PhD research so as I
said Shore developed this algorithm to
factor the problem the product of two
large primes in polynomial time and this
has been the killer application of
quantum computers once once we have one
of course and darvis so DARPA developed
the quantum factoring challenge for the
quantum computing computing community to
look at and this is to factor 128 bit
number on a quantum computer in 30
seconds or less so we know that
factoring is integral to security and
the question is how much of a reality is
this can quantum devices or win will
quantum devices actually be able to
perform this task and today I want to
talk about that reality and what we need
what are the steps to actually achieve a
scalable quantum device
thousand minis dessert
at least yeah
right so this is just the dark book
challenge problem obviously we're not
using 128 bit number in our essay but
the idea is just to be able to get a
quantum device making the steps towards
something that can then you need
thousands more qubits to factor a larger
number so we just want to make the first
steps to actually having a device that
can do something reasonable beyond
factoring 15 which is what we can do now
correct right
you couldn't write this is a good first
first step right which no guarantees
right so um as we know we have a
classical algorithm that can perform
factorization but if it but it's an
exponential time algorithm and this is
using the number field sieve so if we
want to factor a 512-bit number
classically it's going to take 8400 mix
years about and then a 1024 bit number
is going to take 1.6 billion times
longer so clearly this is not practical
but with a quantum algorithm using
Shor's algorithm the complexity is now
polynomial time and we can factor a
512-bit number in three and a half hours
and then a 1024 bit number in about 31
hours question so this is using a
quantum architecture based on an ion
trap device and several layers of
quantum error correction and a 1
gigahertz clock rate of course this
device does not exist currently but
these are and at an outlook for what it
could could potentially do so we have
Shor's algorithm but we currently don't
have a device so in order to make sure
is algorithm a reality we need a
scalable quantum computing device we
need a design flow that takes this
quantum algorithm written in a
high-level language and then maps it to
a fault-tolerant implementation of the
machine instructions to perform on the
quantum device then in order to have
this design flow we need languages and
compilers and different software tools
in order to support this design flow and
then finally we need fault tolerance and
quantum error correction we need fault
tolerance and quantum error correction
in order to achieve reliability in our
computation now of course the second and
third bullets these are
things we need for for classical
computing as well the key is we also
need to incorporate fault tolerance and
quantum error correction into this
design flow yes
top my head I can come to me out
you need the language is the high level
programming
white one Andrew and machine code
um what you could I mean people now are
hand machine coding but the idea is that
you want something you want to be able
maybe with a high-level language it
would give you more insight into how
create how to create more quantum
algorithms and then this process of
adding optimization is very key in a
quantum computer we have such limited
resources so if we can automatically
optimize a quantum circuit before
passing it to the machine that would be
that would be ideal reducing the number
cubist required or reducing the time
required to perform the algorithm so
these things with an optimization phases
would be helpful
sure for a particular device particular
gate set yeah you'd hand tool
optimizations for different cost
functions but those could carry over to
different devices and different circuits
right right it's going to be a
special-purpose device but
um
alright so we have Shor's algorithm and
this is Shor's algorithm written in
pseudocode and you see in the black in
the black type this is these are
operations that are performed on a
classical device so we have classical
pre and post processing and then the red
the red instruction order is the
operation that is actually performed on
the quantum device so you can see that
the essence of Shor's algorithm or the
insight that Shore had was that he was
able to reduce factoring to order
finding and he knew that using a quantum
device which can only perform unitary
transforms and measurement so it has to
be completely reversible using a quantum
advice he was able to perform order
finding quickly or in polynomial time
and so with this insight he was able to
then perform factoring um so you can see
that this is indicative of the computing
environment that we're going to need in
quantum computation and also the
programming environment that we require
so we're requiring quantum computing
that we have an environment that can
support the interspersing of classical
and quantum instructions as you see here
now in order to be able to run Shor's
algorithm on a quantum device we have to
be able to now translate this into
machine instructions for a particular
device or for technology simulator so we
need a language we need a high-level
language we need intermediate
representations and we also need
compilers in order to accomplish this
translation down to the actual physical
device and this is what I'd like to talk
about
so what I've done with ala ala ho Andrew
cross I trong an eager Markov is I've
developed a design flow that takes a
quantum program written in a high-level
language and then translates it down to
machine instructions to actually run on
a quantum device or technology simulator
now you can see that this design flow
for computer scientist this looks very
standard it looks like a traditional
compiler so we have a standard front end
which really is similar to the standard
front end in a traditional compiler
where we translate into an intermediate
representation but then from this point
on the details of each of these boxes
these phases are very different than
what you find in a classical compiler so
now we have an intermediate
representation which is not like three a
dress code anymore this is now something
based on the quantum circuit model which
now abstracts quantum mechanics in
linear algebra we then have the
optimization phases both technology
independent and technology dependent
optimization phases which again have to
work on the abstraction of a quantum
circuit and and then we have a physical
operations language which takes into
account the details of the actual device
you're going to be running your
algorithm on which we then eventually
pass to the actually actual simulator or
quantum device and so the key in
computer science is the goal of computer
science is to provide abstractions for
more difficult problems so we here we
take into account we abstract the
quantum algorithm into the high level
language and then the intermediate
representations provide the abstraction
of a quantum circuit and then finally
the machine instructions for the quantum
device so already we've taken a problem
that was fairly straightforward in the
classical setting and now we have very
different details in the
different phases of this design flow so
what are the benefits of this time type
of software architecture um well since
we have languages and intermediate
representations predefined this means
that we can have tool interoperability
it's easy to add and maintain the tools
and we can have wider community
participation so we have defined
interfaces where for example at MIT
they're working on building a device
simulator for the ion trap they can now
work on this independently of for
example Igor Markov who works on circuit
optimizations at the University of
Michigan so these people can each work
on these different tools independently
and then because we have defined
intermediate representations and
interfaces we can then put these
together into the larger tool chain so
we have Y community participation here
also the tool chain allows you to
evaluate different technologies by using
simulators and so on before actually
building the technology in the lab or
pouring lots of lots of money into a
certain device before you know if it's
going to be scalable so now I'd like to
talk about the the details of our design
flow in a bit more detail and so the
quantum intermediate representation so a
standard intermediate representation
might be the three might be three a
dress code well here this is a very very
different type of representation now our
intermediate representation is based on
the quantum circuit model and the
quantum circuit is made up of qubits
which an analogous to a classical bit
except now they take on the value of
zero one or a superposition of zero and
one so here we have two qubits and then
in quantum circuits you have only
unitary transforms and then measurement
here I'm not showing a measurement
operation I just have to unitary
transforms H represents the Hatta
margate here and then this skate here is
a controlled not gain and this whole
circuit performs what makes an epr pair
and Einstein Podolsky Rosen pair so here
this is the mathematical representation
of an epr pair for different values of
X&Y here now it's important to note
about this quantum circuit model is that
unlike in classical computing when you
would have a single output value on each
wire here in quantum mechanic 10
computation these outfits are actually
entangled so we can't separately look at
x and y these are entangled output so
you can see how this is going to affect
for example the optimization phase it's
much more complicated now to optimize a
circuit such such as this well or that
would have the same properties as as a
quantum this quantum circuit
so in the optimization phase what was
previously fairly straightforward to
perform optimization on three a dress
code dead code elimination people
optimization loop optimization the
optimization noun of a quantum circuit
is not straightforward so it is even
difficult it to know the optimal circuit
to represent it to the N by 2 than
unitary matrix and only recently in the
past three years have the upper bounds
and lower bounds been matched for theta
4 to the n elementary gates to represent
it to the N x to the N unitary matrix
even more difficult is optimizing
circuits involved in error correction
error correction circuits have a certain
property they have to achieve they have
to prevent the spread of errors and also
correct errors in the quantum circuit
and so if you optimize and change the
order of gates or change the type of
gates the spread of air the spread of
airs through the circuit changes so this
becomes more difficult to optimize
circuits and error correction and these
circuits some error correction circuits
are called stabilizer circuits because
of the gates that are involved in the
circuit and you see that this stabilizer
circuit takes open squared log in
controlled not hatim are in phase gates
in the output circuit so what was
previously a fairly easy phase is now
fairly difficult in in our design flow
and this is so I I worked on some
quantum circuit optimizations that
helped achieve the matching upper and
lower bounds without a hoe and this work
I presented at equus quantum conference
in Japan
so now we have the quantum assembly
language so traditionally a traditional
assembly language is based on the von
Neumann architecture and now in quantum
computing we don't have a standard
architecture so we're going to keep the
assembly language independent of the
device at this point so on the right
hand side I have a sample assembly code
that represents the outputs the same
computes and epr pair the same circuit
as I showed on with the previous slides
so our assembly language is a typed
assembly language we have three types we
have a qubit type a classical called see
bit type and then we have gate and you
see here we declare we have two qubits x
and y we declare that gates a hat amor
gate and a/c not gate written as C X and
then we perform these gates on the
qubits and again quantum instructions
are solely unitary transforms unitary
gates and measurements but in our
quantum assembly language we can also
make classical calls for a complete
classical instruction set Andrew cross
and I have developed this chasm assembly
language
yes
you say perfectly
possible
wall construction I mean in that case
very well be
technology and I guess this is not
really assembly language
right we call it an assembly language
but it's not identical to what you think
of as a classical assembly language so
you can have another level right mm-hmm
right so chasm lies here in our design
flow between the technology independent
optimization and technology dependent
optimization and within our optimization
phases we assume we have code generation
so chasm chasm of is made up of a
certain set of unitary gates and
according to the device we might need to
translate into a different set of
unitary gates and so that would be done
in the technology dependent optimizer it
would generate physical operations
language code with a specific set of
gates that can be computed on the
specific device and it would be
optimized for first certain maybe
certain gates can't be computed on the
device do you optimize over certain gate
sets number of qubits etc so the
objective function of the optimization
phase can change according to your
device number of qubits number of gates
stage
that
since you may have to make you have
essentially able to be optimized it
could undo a lot of the optimizations
right so between the quantum
intermediate representation and the
chasm code in the technology independent
optimization we've actually changed in
Qi are we actually assume that we don't
it's a universal set of gates it can be
any gate um whereas in chasm we assume
that we now have changed to a discrete
set of gates so um this is one one of
the differences between q qi r and
chasms they might you know might very
well resemble each other very closely we
q ir and the high-level languages have
not are open research problems at this
point so for example you translating it
into classical assembly language to buy
some stuff
necessary
right might as well just write that can
just exist in a separate you've
separated out the quantum and the
classical instructions somewhere along
here and so the classical instructions
that sit separately from the quantum
instruction set what we're doing in this
design flow is just trying to optimize
for example just the order function call
in Shor's algorithm so we're converting
that into chasm so we're just and then
you would reassemble the classical pre
and post processing instructions and
then this classical or this quantum set
of instruction would be passed the
quantum device but there has to be some
communication between the classical and
quantum device and the exact setup of
that is still undecided so we've just
separated it out at this point right so
the optimization phase you have
different objective functions that you
can optimize over and in the technology
dependent optimization phase these
switch to a gate set that would be
doable on the actual quantum device that
you're going to send to so for example
you have one possible technologies the
ion trap there are many possible
technologies being researched currently
in labs across the world ion trap is one
others are quantum dots NMR which isn't
scalable but people have looked into
that but here I'd like to talk about the
ion trap and this is a device simulator
that has been um been built at MIT under
I Kwang and his students and Ike
actually built our help to build the
world's first quantum computer which was
NMR based and it can factor the number
15 into five times three um so it's it's
not quite scalable yet but he did work
on that and he feels that the ion trap
is going to be is a very promising
technology so up at MIT he's working on
building the ion trap and different
components of the ion trap so the
simulator helps him and other physicists
visualize what's going on in the device
and also determine what kind of failure
rates will occur before he actually
builds this in the lab so the simulator
just to tell you what this is this this
is for the ion trap and the ion trap
lies in some layout in this case this is
called an H tree layout so this is um
the ions represent the qubits and they
sit in locations and then they have to
move along channels in the trap in order
to interact with other islands um so
these ions might move up here sit here
and then they're adjacent to other ions
in an ion trap in order to perform a
multi cubic gate like the controlled not
gate ions have to be adjacent so we call
this a local setting they have to be
local so these ions are local and then
these flashes are gates being applied so
in an ion trap a gate is applied by a
laser so these lasers hit the ions
perform a gate and then you have iron
traps also can require things like
cooling and joining so they have to
close eye on join the ions into a change
they can interact and so on and then
they would move back along these
channels it's just an overview of what
an iron truck looks like I'm so the
simulator provides a visualization for
the physicists of what's occurring
actually in the ion trap device so in
order to build our design flow Ike
invited me to MIT to work with him and
the students and to learn more actually
about the ion trap since if we're going
to build the design flow we have to
understand both the source language and
the target device so i worked at MIT
last year with ike on the design flow
and also on different error correction
schemes
but again this is just one type of
device that might look like on the back
end of our compiler and then the
physical operations language would be
the provides the machine instructions
that are then passed to the physical
actual device or simulator and again
since the architecture is not set in
quantum computing we will have many
different q pools many different
physical operations language languages
for the different devices that we might
have um and the physical operations
language it takes into account the
layout the geometry of the architecture
in this case the grid for the ion trap
you see that we're declaring the ion is
a data type ion and it's going to lie in
this location so we have layout
instructions we have other system
specific instructions as well such as
cooling and joining which isn't shown in
this in this snippet of code but we also
have movement as I discussed in ion
traps the ions have to move together to
interact so we have a movement operation
here and this is a snippet of code that
also perform that also prepares an epr
state as the circuit I showed earlier
does so what we've seen is that we've
seen we can abstract take abstract the
physical system into a mathematical
model on which we can then pass along
our design flow we can take the
mathematical model and come up with a
computational formalism or a quantum
circuit model and that represents the
mathematics of our quantum algorithm and
then we can translate this into an
intermediate representation and an
assembly language down to a physical
actual physical operations language the
machine instructions to pass to the
physical system which eventually in this
case is laser pulse is applied to ions
in an ion trap so here this is just a
review of taking the mathematics to the
quantum circuit and then down to our
different machine
structions and eventually to the
physical device now the big question i
took this design flow to david do
Vincenzo and Barber tahala IBM and the
big question for them was well this is
this is great but where along this
design flow do we put in error
correction so quantum computing the
components and a quantum device are
inherently noisy so we have to for a
scalable device we have to have quantum
error correction we have to have fault
tolerance this is very different than in
a classical setting where CMOS is
naturally robust so what I'd like to
talk about now is where along this
design flow should we put fault
tolerance and quantum error correction
and what does it mean to do quantum
error correction how is it different
than classical error correction and I'll
show you that so is quantum information
processing scalable so here on this
orange line represents a quantum gate
and here we have the magnitude of a
perturbation of a quantum state or the
magnitude of a perturbation of a voltage
on a transistor versus the probability
that the circuit fails after applying
that gate in the technology so in the
quantum case this has a linear
relationship and in the CMOS case it has
a much more desirable curve so what we
want to be able to do is with some
mechanism some means we have to take
this orange line and we have to push it
to resemble the red the red curve here
and how do we do that
so in so what we can do in four to make
the quantum gate more reliable as we can
add quantum error correction so you can
see that by adding quantum error
correction the previously linear line
now resembles the red curve which is
exactly what we need to produce a robust
quantum computer so inclined error
correction you can have different levels
of coding is called concatenation this
is just one approach you could have a
large block code as well but today I'm
going to talk about concatenation in
error correction so what this means is
we can have less coding or we have more
coding and if we have more coding if
we're below some threshold the threshold
here means that if our air rates of our
components in our quantum circuit or
quantum device are below this value this
vertical line here then actually adding
quantum error correction will make our
circuit more reliable but if we're above
that point above that threshold then our
quantum circuit actually becomes noisier
with the addition of quantum error
correction so we want to be able to
determine what this threshold value is
so that we know our guarantee the error
correction is actually making our device
more reliable and we want to know that
failure rate of the component that's
necessary so that when we try to build a
device in the lab we have a target error
rate and if we achieve that target error
rate or below that target array then we
know our computation is going to be
scalable and reliable so if we have less
coding you can see that by adding more
coding above the threshold more coding
could actually make it even noisier not
not better so I want to talk about how
we can theoretically analyze what this
threshold value is in a quantum for our
quantum devices
so the elements of fault tolerance in a
quantum computer well we know that we
have to have fault tolerance which is
includes quantum error correction we
have to have fault tolerance for
scalability our components are too noisy
if we don't have if we don't have fault
tolerance and we can achieve fault
tolerance by using what's called
concatenated coding concatenation and
this is the method I'm going to talk
about today and then we also have the
threshold theorem which says that if our
components are below a certain failure
rate then even though they are faulty we
can still achieve a reliable robust
computation and in addition to thinking
about fault tolerance just in general we
have to also take into account whether
or not locality is essential in our
architecture so do we have to
incorporate movement so we have to think
about the geometry and the layout of the
device that we're going to be using so
classically if we have an and gate you
can say that this NAND gate fails with
probability P then we can use triple
modular redundancy encoding to make this
NAND gate more reliable so this is how
we make the NAND gate fault tolerant as
we place a single man by three Nan's in
other words what we're doing is we're
taking it we're encoding the data a
single 0 bit is encoded in three and a
single one is encoded in 3 1 bits so for
the NAND gate then we repeat the nan
three times and then we're going to
follow it by these three majority games
now this performs the same same task as
than a single NAND gate we assume that
each one of these gates fails with
probability P and then what happens is
now previously the single gate filled
with probability P well now the cert
this circuit feels only if two gates to
gates fail it yes
majority well then you look at the you
have to decode these three bits again
another gateway right but it's not this
is going to improve the reliability of
your circuit so previously so now the
probability of failure of this whole
module is less than or equal to 6 p
square because we have to have two
components failing and there's six ways
for these two to fail so if p is less
than or equal to 1 over 6 then this
module is more reliable than the single
nand gate and we should use this instead
now we can repeat this process again so
this is called what we call
concatenation so we're we repeat again
we replace each of the three NAND gates
before with the entire module so now we
have a level two encoding and it's a
recursive construction so we replaced 0
with three zeros before now each of
those zeros gets to replace by 30 so we
have 90 and 91 s representing 0 1 and
now this circuit fails only if two
modules fail so two of these big dashed
boxes so we can see again that the
probability of failure of this this
whole circuit is now less than or equal
to 6 times 6 p squared squared which we
get by just plugging in and then the
probability we can say that the
probability of failure is less than or
equal to CP to the K over C
so I just plugged in for 6c was 61
overseas sick so now what we can do is
we we drive the fault tolerant special
theorem and this was actually done by
von Neumann in 1956 so this is not new
to the classical community and so using
Kayla recursive levels of era correction
in the previous slide I showed two
levels we can get we get this result
where the probability of failure of the
entire circuit over the threshold is
equal to this is the initial gate
failure the initial failure of any
component in the circuit over the
threshold and then k is the level of
error correction so this carries over to
the quantum setting as well so the
threshold theorem is that we can achieve
good reliable computation with faulty
components as long as the error rates of
the components are below this threshold
value P Thresh which is one over C as I
showed in the previous slide but in
quantum fault tolerance we can't exactly
just copy is do redundancy codes as we
did in the classical case in the
classical case we used a TMR code in
quantum fall terms we can't do that we
can't just copy the information well for
one reason is because there is no
copying allowed in quantum computation
so we cannot duplicate a quantum state
also it's now more difficult in the
classical setting we had bit flip pairs
in the quantum setting now we have a
continuum of errors on each qubit but
luckily we can discretize these errors
and just look for bit in phase flippers
but already bitten phase flippers is
more difficult than just bid flippers
and in addition if we measure our
quantum information then this destroys
the quantum state so we can't look at
our computation we can't look at our
data and ask what errors are on our data
we have to have some other means of
transferring those errors somewhere else
which were what we're going to do is
we'll transfer will spread the airs on
to what are called in syllabus which are
like work bits and so we can get we can
overcome this obstacle of measurement by
measuring work bits because we don't
care if we destroy their state as long
as we see what the heirs were on the
data beforehand so now I'd like to talk
a little bit about what quantum error
correction is so in this talk I'm just
going to focus on 713 error correction
so what this means is that we take a
single qubit and we encode it in seven
cubits and it's a distance 3 code so it
can correct just one error so this is an
example of what error correction looks
like for quantum computing so our data
sits on this upper wire and the slash
means that actually represents seven
cubits in this case so we have seven
cubits that we want an air correct and
what we can do is all of these 0 states
all of these 0 qubits are work qubits
there in Silla and we can use them to
read or to determine what errors
actually lie on the data and we do this
by preparing them the G network is a
preparation and then V is a verification
network and all these boxes include many
gates inside them much circuitry in each
box so we prepare and verify that RN
silica bits are in some state and then
this F box is called syndrome extraction
we can extract syndrome information from
the data so we can spread the errors
that are on the data down to the insula
and then we can look at the insula by
measurement and determine what errors
are on the data and then using this
information we can control the recovery
some recovery process to the data by
applying some quantum gates back on the
data so that we restore the data to the
state we want
so in more detail and the preparation
network looks something like this so it
consists of several hatim our gates and
several controlled not gates so we
prepare our n Scylla into this zero
logical state and then we verify that
it's in this state by using controlled Z
gates padam our gates and then measuring
to check if we're indeed in this state
so you can see that air Christian is
quite complicated and involves adding a
lot of gates to our circuit so what we
want to do is we want to be able to
determine away a method to replace each
each gate in the quantum circuit with
its fault tolerant procedure so that
then when we put the whole procedure the
whole thing is fault tolerant and
reliable so what we've done is we've
I've come up with the replacement role
model with David DiVincenzo in barberton
Hall and the idea is that a quantum
circuit consists of many types of
locations control not gates how to Mar
gates measurements many different types
um what we want to do is we want to
replace each location in the original
circuit by its fault tolerant version
which means that we replace it by error
correction so that we correct the errors
before they get to the gate and then a
fault-tolerant implementation of the
original gate and we can do this
repeatedly to obtain the concatenated
version of the original circuit we're
and we do it recursively say K times so
what this looks like is that we have a 2
cubic gate you for example it could be a
controlled not gate and an axon cubits p
and q well in the 713 Co we replace each
qubit we encode it in seven cubits so
the P a single p cube it becomes seven
cubits and similarly for the q and then
what we want to do is we want to err
correct these qubits before we before we
actually perform the implementation of
the gate so that we remove some of the
airs so that when they reach the gate
they don't spread so air correction here
in this case for a 713 code it'll
correct a single single bit flip error
in a single face flip error in each one
of these boxes and again this e is the
entire circuits I showed earlier with
many little box many little boxes
exactly um yes if you recurse too many
levels of concatenation will never be
practical but the idea is you want to
find what level concatenation will
achieve the reliability reliability you
need in your quantum device so maybe
just one level a large block code if you
have a code that can correct many errors
so a larger distance code would be a
much better idea here as long as you
don't have too many qubits involved then
it becomes too costly
basically the noise models well yeah the
noise models are sort of what have
problems are closer to me two qubits
revealed individually or is it okay that
subjective schubas would fail so that
take a path through the concatenated
circuits and that
right so there's some obviously in
different technologies different things
are going to fail differently because
you you make a qubit like for example in
ions you have random field fluctuations
I think that's one of the predominant
noise causes so you have different noise
causes in these different technologies
but you can assume that just for
achieving a ballpark threshold estimate
the idea here is most likely this
replacement rule won't be used exactly
as it's written here but this provides a
theoretical argument for why quantum
computation couldn't be be scalable so
we want to just perform a general
assessment of what the threshold might
be for the different components of the
quantum circuit so you just assume that
you seem that different gates fail
independently with some probability of
an X X Y or Z air so bit flip or face
flip or some combination of bit flip and
Facebook bears and so using these
assumptions you just you just achieve a
ballpark estimate of a threshold but
obviously in quantum computing there's
many other types of noise than just that
failing so you have different
interactions with the environment you
have different crosstalk crosstalk is a
big problem so accounting for these you
you actually need to use many different
methods than just quantum error
correction so many of those protecting
against those types of noise mostly the
physicists are working on right now but
what we want to be able to do is just
guarantee that even the quantum circuit
is going to be reliable because at this
point if if you don't have error
correction you don't have fault
tolerance and one of the gates fails
then your whole computation is likely to
fail because of how spares spread
throughout a circuit so we just from a
theoretical standpoint want to be able
to prevent the spread of errors and then
this will be one level of the process to
achieving a robust computation in
general
so um right so then we have a
fault-tolerant implementation of the
actual gate and we do this in a way such
that it doesn't spread to many ears
because if we have too many airs on one
block of these qubits than those qubits
are those they're just incorrect they're
worthless so we want to prevent the
number of errors in each block of these
qubits and we do this by doing a
fault-tolerant implementation of this
gate and for a two qubit gate in certain
codes this means a transversal
implementation which is just a bitwise
bitwise implementation so we'd perform
OC not between p0 q 0 p1 q1 and this
would prevent the spread of errors from
p0 to q3 for example so for each type of
location in our mont and art quantum
circuit we have such a replacement rule
and the again e and the way we do you is
dependent on the code so in different
codes it's difficult sometimes to find a
good implementation that's why for now
we're sticking with the 713 code because
it has nice representations of the gates
when we have to do them fault tolerant
Lee so as I said before we have two
types of architectures we have an
architecture where the qubits have to be
adjacent to interact and then we have an
architecture where there's no
restriction on the distance between the
qubits to perform a multi Cuba operation
so clearly if we require that qubits
have to be spatially adjacent this is
going to change our replacement rules so
a question we also want to ask is does
there exist a threshold in the local
setting when we require movement and if
the threshold exists what is this
threshold because for example an ion
trap it wasn't known if it was going to
be scalable if there actually was a
threshold because there was all this
movement required and when you
concatenate there's even more movement
so with all of this movement do we still
have a threshold and this is what I'd
like to talk about now
so um with David divincenzo and barber
talked to halt I wanted to answer this
question of how locality exactly affects
the threshold and this is work that we
published in physical review a and we
also presented at q IP which is the
quantum quantum conference so the idea
here is that let each of these boxes
these larger boxes represent a single
qubit that's been concatenated once so
each single qubit is now represented by
seven day two cubits and say the seven
day two cubits sit in this light grey
area and then as you saw in air
correction we require a lot of work
qubits to perform erection so these
qubits sit in the middle here these this
white box so each of these qubits now on
the next level concatenation each one is
encoded in seven and then all of these
now require and solos for error
correction so upon concatenation again
each of these light gray data qubits is
now in one of these larger boxes here
and all of them have their insole is for
error correction and then the insole is
on the middle are now concatenated again
as well and so then they have their
installers for air correction also in
the middle and the darkness of the gray
indicates the amount of moving needs to
be done so here these light gray qubits
they had to move distance a order our or
some scale factor of the distance now at
the next level of concatenation they
have to move distance R squared and so
on up to K levels they have to move
distance order our to the K so you can
see that this is a problem if you have
to concatenate to high levels you have a
lot of movement you have to consider and
movement is noisy so we have to require
the error correction is done in transit
and you also have to have the space in
your layout to account for all this
additional error correction
so what we'd like to do is see how
locality affects threshold and you can
see previously it's been these are
threshold estimates the year versus the
actual threshold estimate I'm just over
the past 10 years and you can see that
people have estimated in the mid-90s
late 90s most of the threshold estimates
lie it were between 10 to the minus 5
and 10 to minus 6 so a component of a
quantum computer failed feeling at the
rate of 10 to minus 10 to the minus 5
would be reliable but you can see that
in recent years actually the threshold
has gotten a lot better and that these
estimates by steen and ricart are closer
to 10 of minus 2 into minus 3 now if i
have a quantum computer that has a
failure rate or the components fail at a
rate of 10 to minus 2 or 10 to the minus
3 and i build this you know I put my
quantum algorithm on it I want to
guarantee that it's actually going to be
reliable so I want to know why there's
this discrepancy between these recent
threshold estimates and previous
threshold estimates so what is the real
threshold so what Barbara David and
myself did is we came up with a new
analysis method to more accurately
determine what the threshold should be
for both the non-local and local
architectures so these lie I talked
about different levels of catenation
these are all for the 713 code the same
code but some of these threshold
estimates are achieved by looking at
only one level of concatenation so
what's the failure rate after one level
and if you recall i showed the graph
where more coding could lower your
threshold further well if you so it's
not so some of these look too high level
some look only to low levels of
catenation so what we did is we
developed this replacement role model
that determines how locality actually
affects the threshold and what we do is
we use these replacement roles as I
showed and we recursively apply them and
we develop an analysis of each
replacement rule determine how each
replacement rule would fail
and then we estimate the local and
non-local thresholds for the 7 cubic
code so as an overview of our analysis
what we do is we look at the probability
of crash or this failure probability
function for each location types
replacement roles so for the replacement
role for a head a morgue a replacement
rule 4 a c naught K and so on so at each
level K you use the location failure
probabilities from the previous level to
determine the location fill your
probability for the current level and
you plug into this failure probability
function that we come up with and then
you can determine at each level
concatenation what the reliability is so
what does this mean so again this is the
circuit for the EPR pair if at the first
level ademar fails with failure
probability gamma 1 and the C naught
fails with probability gamma 2 then we
apply our replacement rules and so these
dash box dash boxes represent the
replacement rule we have error
correction plus the gate and again these
are operating Alan seven cubits so this
is a transfer these are transversal
gates then we can use the failure
probability function for this original
hatim our location for the replacement
role and achieve the new failure
probability of the whole whole dash box
which is gamma 1 Prime and then the new
failure probability of this will dash
box gamma 2 Prime and so on so we do
this for each type of location and we do
this recursively so then we repeat each
gate in this box is replaced by the dash
box and so on we do this to a high
enough level so that we can determine if
the original failure probability vector
gamma 1 gamma 2 was above or below
threshold so we start with a vector
failure probabilities of the locations
so this has the initial failure
probabilities for all the components of
our circuit and we map this on to the
next on to gamma of 1 and so on up to a
high enough level a high enough k so
that we can determine if the initial
failure probability back initial vector
of failure probabilities is above
threshold or below threshold it's below
threshold if it
20 it's above threshold if it heads to
infinity and again we have a failure
probability function for each type of
location so just to give it give you an
idea it's a very high dimensional map in
the non-local case we have only we have
five types of locations in our circuit
so we have a five dimensional map and in
the local case we now have to
incorporate movement and different types
of waiting and so on and this becomes an
eight dimensional map and more recently
we've looked at a more explicit local
architecture where it's actually a 18
dimensional map so it's a very high
level map but we can still determine the
thresholds from this so this is a graph
of the failure probability of a single
qubit gate versus the failure
probability of a 2 cubic gate these are
the initial setting so initially the
whole vector is set to the failure
probability of a single qubit gate
except a weight gate is a tenth of that
value so what this means is that here we
have 3.9 times 10 to minus 4 is the
initial failure probability of the
components now with one application of
our map and the failure probability
falls to around 1.4 1.1 times 10-4 so
you can see that it's heading toward
zero it's decreasing so if we had
stopped here if we cut here and we only
applied one level then we might think
that this was a actually indeed below
threshold so this gives you some idea of
why the threshold estimates line
different or there's a description
discrepancy between previous threshold
estimates but at the next level you can
see that we apply our map again and it's
now actually starting to go up and again
it's going up and so now tending to
infinity so it takes this big turn so
actually 3.9 times 10-4 is above
threshold and if we had built our
quantum computer with that failure rate
it wouldn't be reliable and similarly
43.7 x 2mm is for but then for 3.5 and
3.3 times n minus 4 you can see that
after one iteration is going
and then after another iteration another
level of recursion it continues to go
down so in this case 3.5 and 3.3 times
cinema is for both below threshold so
you can see that we have to look at high
levels of catenation to determine what
the real threshold is and it's also
important that you look at many of the
different types of components that are
in your circuit because a weight gate
might be much more reliable than a
single qubit gate but if you determine
that the whole circuit can fail at the
failure probability of the weight gate
then your circuits not going to be
reliable so it's important to account
for these different types of locations
and actually have a five or eight
dimensional map so you can see that then
our threshold estimates we do this for
the local and the non-local case we
achieve a threshold estimate around 10
to the minus 4 for the non-local setting
and around 10 to the minus 5 for the
local setting so you can see that these
threshold estimates might indeed be
inaccurate or what we call pseudo
thresholds it's a fake estimate it's not
a real threshold estimate it won't give
you an accurate or reliable computation
and recently our results had been
further ala ferrous and his colleagues
have found a lower bound and it is
indeed closer to our threshold estimates
so this has been partially confirmed
so what we did is we performed the first
assessment of how exactly locality
influences the threshold and we further
show that there does exist a threshold
for a general local layout and our
method we can use this method of
analysis to determine the threshold for
each type of technology and error
correction code so that now we can
evaluate different aircraft and codes
and different era correction and
fault-tolerant schemes and we can also
evaluate different architectures in
advance of building them in a lab so
back to the design flow so we have this
so now we know how to perform fault
tolerance and quantum error correction
but we still don't know where in the
design flow this should go so it could
possibly go at the software level or
perhaps it could even go at the hardware
level so it's an open research question
where in this design flow we should
place fault tolerance in software we
could apply something like the
replacement role model and then generate
the technology dependent code and then
we could possibly use scheduling
algorithms and different layout tools
that preserve the fault tolerance on the
other hand we could look at a more
hardware based approach and we could
apply fault tolerance in a way we would
create Universal fault tolerant device
specific components and then we publish
how to connect these components and this
would be another method of achieving
fault tolerance and air correction but
in reality I believe it's going to be
some combination of heart a hardware
based approach and software based
approach for example we might require a
different type of code all together we
could actually look at a more physical
based code like a topological code which
would be more of a hardware hardware
based approach
so in conclusion I've shown that
theoretically quantum computing can be
made reliable and scalable which is good
news but I've shown that in order to
achieve this we require a design flow
that transforms this quantum algorithm
written in the high-level language into
the machine instructions for the quantum
device and I've shown that this design
flow is indeed very different than the
standard compiler you have for your
classical computer it requires very
different intermediate representations
such as the quantum circuit model and
different optimizations for the
optimization phases in addition we
require fault tolerance and quantum
error correction and one way to analyze
different aircraft and codes and fault
tolerance methods is to use for example
the replacement role model and the
analysis method I discussed it also
requires both these fault tolerance
threshold analyses can help then
physicists develop quantum devices it
can give them a target error rate if
they can achieve such a target air rate
they have a better idea of whether or
not they'll be able to achieve reliable
and scalable quantum computation so this
is a great news but we still need an
actual physical device with a low
failure rate and a long coherence time
and of course this is a long quantum
computing it's a very long term research
project physicists tend to like long
term projects so this is this is one of
them we also need many more qubits so we
have quantum error correction techniques
but as we concatenate it requires many
many qubits on the further we
concatenate if we use a large block code
it still requires many qubits and just
Shor's algorithm without error
correction requires thousands of qubits
so we need many more qubits in our in
our quantum device and then we also need
quantum error correction methods that
have better air crafting properties
whether that the encoding with fewer
numbers of qubits
detecting or detecting and correcting
against higher numbers of errors so all
of these things will be necessary to
achieve a reliable scalable quantum
computer thanks for a few iterations
they and everything proven i think that
they go bad again I never do more than
me computed a bike right well actually
it's a good point because in the lab
when you actually build the physical
device you might only do two or three
levels and maybe at the fourth level it
goes up so at that in that case yes it
for you want to for the for building a
device you don't care if it goes up
after a certain number but you need to
know if it goes up after a certain
number in the sense that if you
concatenate further it might become
unreliable if you didn't know that that
threshold was really above above
threshold in the sense of how I've
defined above and below threshold so
from a theoretical standpoint we want to
know where the guaranteed what the
guaranteed threshold rate is but for
actually building the device you want to
know what levels of concatenation are
necessary to achieve the reliability you
want so yes that's it's a very good
point
any other question
yep you were sense
like these ion trap devices me
um right so um there's a group in
Switzerland that are they're making good
progress they have I think they can
achieve ten cubits right now can stay
coherent remain coherent for a small
amount of time I'm not sure the exact
time scale and recently actually they
were able if you remember in the HT
layout you have these channels and you
have to return around ninety two corners
and actually turning around and turning
cubitt ions around and I need agree
corner is actually very difficult and
recently they were able to achieve that
at MIT what they've been working on is
actually the lasers controlling the
lasers which is another large problem in
ion traps how do you control the lasers
and precisely target a single ion in
this large I well small and trap but in
the larger and the larger ion trap so
they've been working on tuning these
lasers and applying just very specific
gates and they have achieved um not an
MIT but another lab they've applied see
not gate and so on it's slowly coming
along i think the reliability the
concern is clearly numbers of qubits and
how you're going to fit that many qubits
and act on them independently i think
that's one of the major major problems
right now but i think they're slowly
making progress on this I think I
entraps are are very promising as a
technology for quantum computing
it's really tiny yeah but so then when
you you can extend the computer by
connecting ion traps together problem is
is that with quantum error correction
right now not to sound negative but if
you required right now with the current
reliability of different components of
the ion trap system you'd actually have
to have so much concatenate I think like
seven levels of concatenation which
would cause your iron trap to view the
size of a football field which clearly
is impractical but I mean of course
you're not going to use the 7 cubic code
in reality in practice you're going to
use something else so it's I mean this
is a very long-term project obviously
and so any small step is it's really
it's a big step just you know moving
around a corner or just keeping the
qubits coherent for some amount of time
so
oh yeah okay thank you